[Musik]
[Applaus]
der tür von hinten
ich habe hier die botschaft von seinem
enkel frederik aus münchen
weil er ja nicht da sein kann zu ostern
und ich bin so gespannt was ihr übel
sagt und wie sehr berührt von dieser
botschaft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir sind voll von der bild-zeitung und
haben eine botschaft für sie eine
osterbotschaft von ihrer familie aus
münchen und die wollte man ihnen jetzt
mal zeigen dass ich zu oft überholt
ich bin fahren das kann man nicht reden
können und ich ähm ja ist band an um die
freundlich wenn er sicher nicht gehen
[Musik]
sie sehen also es ist sehr sehr
eindrucksvoll
da habe ich natürlich nicht mitgerechnet
lieber hendrik ich war eben doch sehr
sehr gerührt und auch weich geworden und
jetzt möchte ich mich ganz ganz herzlich
für dieses wunderschöne klavierspiel
bedanken dass also mich doch sehr sehr
berührt hat und ich möchte euch ein
entzückendes schönes osterfest 5
trotz der desolaten situation jetzt mit
der krone situation alles alles gute
euch und schönen dank für diese riesige
überraschung die also hervorragend
angekommen ist alles gute und schöne
grüße bitter noch an den vielen eltern
[Musik]